so as i reloaded
and
went pointed the gun
is when he jumped in the back of the van
but i ran to the passenger side and then
shot through the passenger side window
[Music]
you were growing up at in manchester's
most solid yeah well in the early 90s
there was um two gangs that have been at
war so
yeah
from a young age you're exposed to um
gang violence and gang-related activity
you know so what should have really been
um
frightening to a young person or
deterred a young person from it it
normalized it somewhat glamorized it as
well
the first time i got involved with crime
i'd say i was about 12 or 13 years old
my thing was more driving underage but
then when i was 13 is when um
i got my first firearm
my circle of friends we had we had the
name of our um
gang let's say was the drive by crew so
then people would always like make fun
of us and laugh and joke and be like oh
how are you called the drive-by crew and
you don't have a gun to use don't drive
so as simple as that we went out and
got ourselves a car and got ourselves a
go
how many of you were there about four of
us and all very young yeah all the same
age was all the same major all in the
same year in school
or from the same area
started off like selling weed driving
around like i said under underage
had this gun we never shot the gun we
just used to brandish it and
show people
and things like that and then like
street robberies on a minor scale so
what starts off as
like i said driving around then i might
have all the gang members in my car
giving them a lift driving them
somewhere then it's as simple as
being seen by somebody and then you're
let from that point on you're labeled a
gang member
were you worried about your family being
targeted
yeah family's been targeted
to be honest
you know there was a time when
i've gone to a takeaway with my mum
mum saying to me let me go let me go in
i'm saying nice sweetheart going
going in there when i'm studying there
waiting for my food the door's open
behind me it's one of my enemies
he's bouncing around
and then um
i've ended up leaving but then he was in
the doorway next to the takeaway i was
in
and i heard the gun [ __ ]
so i'm just walking to the car but i'm
looking at my mum i don't want to make
it obvious you know because everyone's
going to panic
so then we've got in the car
i've already heard the gun be caught you
know so i'm just waiting for them to
start shooting
some say monkey just drive the car and
she drove off then after we drove off
that's when i explained to her what
happened you know but
the level of disrespect involved in
like gang banging
you know like people will do things to
you in front of you more i didn't meet
personally because i that was like one
of my rules
you know i'm not going to disrespect
somebody's mother
because of the love i had for my mum and
my grand
i lived a double life you know even till
this day when my mum hears some of the
things that i speak about
it's almost like a shock to her
when i was 17 i got shot three times
by a rival gang
i was set up in a honey trap
so um a female has lured me to a
location
i've gone to that location and then when
i got there there was like eight to ten
of my rivals waiting for me
then they um shot me three times and
left me for dead in a local park
where did the should go
um
my stomach my back and my leg
i fell asleep in the ambulance and i've
woke up and now i'm in the trauma center
with all my family around me crying
everybody's crying
but
i've not even realized what's really
happened you know i just felt like i
went to sleep and woke up and now
everybody's here my sisters turned to me
and said oh is this the end of it now so
i'm saying so no this is just the
beginning
do you think there was a moment when you
realized that the crime has become your
life
um
it stemmed from
two of my friend well a group of my
friends
they got into this argument with another
guy
over
drug dealing and
you're selling drugs in our area and
x y and z
dave then
had an altercation with this individual
um a shooting's taken place then
he's then
made a statement and got all them
arrested so now they're sat in prison
awaiting trial but then i was on the
outside and with my mentality at this
point
i was saying this individual can't be in
our area
if he's gave a statement to the police
and got my friends locked up i seen a
group of my friends um outside an
address down the road from where i was
staying
and um
when i've approached them they've all
started telling me that oh he's out and
he's looking for you
then while we was having this
conversation
the phone's ranked and it's him and he's
like oh where are you now we're looking
for you
um there's 12 of us we've got six guns
and we're looking for you we're coming
to your mom's house so i thought
i can't really have them coming to my
mom's house so i said i'll come and meet
you
then i went and met him
when i got there i seen them all
um scattered around this van
so as i approached them is when i left
off the first shot
majority of them scattered but this
individual stayed there
so as i reloaded
and
when pointed the gun
is when he jumped in the back of the van
and the van tried to drive off
but i ran to the passenger side and then
shot through the passenger side window
so was it that was an attempt murder
yeah
how much did you get for that
i had the conspiracy to murder on
the um
the hired help because they say i
planned to kill him because he got in
the van then i had the attempted murder
on his cousin which was the driver of
the van and i ended up with a 12-year
ipp
so it's a life sentence for public
protection
and
minimum term 12 years
how old were you when that happened
18 when i got sentenced
how did it all make you feel back then
it's a crazy one because as much as 18
is a young age
looking like from a perspective of
hanging around with gang members from
about
the age of 13
upwards
you know i felt at that point
i was established and older than i was
it was a crazy feeling because
to me i felt like
i've passed all tests now i got shot i
didn't say anything
now i'm in prison for um serious charges
i've not said anything
like i've passed the test you know so
it's almost like a badge of honor is how
i see now at that point
you're going into
prison what were the first sort of days
and nights there like
the first few nights
in all honesty like i had the best sleep
ever
you know because i i was i was no longer
on edge because when i was out it was
like every single day you're expecting
the police to come flying through your
door
every time i'm leaving the house i don't
even know if i'm going to make it home
that day
you know so then being in prison
it's almost like i know
i'm safe if you know what i mean
so i feel i just had the best sleep
ever because the worst thing that can
happen to you in prison is you get
stabbed
you know
and
in all honesty
you kind of have to let somebody get
close enough to stab you if you know
what i mean
prison life in the early stages because
covering local prisons everybody knows
who you are
so that was my first time in prison but
by the time i've got there
i've already got a reputation outside
it's when i come in that reputation and
follows me
into prison
but then as soon as i got convicted for
the conspiracy to murder
they made me
cut a
so at that point i was 19 at that point
and that's when they sent me to
strangers
but then when i went to the kaia unit
now you're with real criminals
you know you're with people that are in
for terrorism charges
um serial killers
you know natural lifers
and
that was the first time i ever met
someone doing a whole life tariff
and the one that stuck him out i'll say
was um dave bieber
the um american bodybuilder
why
because it was him that um
he came to me one day
with a plan
and he's saying to me look you're from
manchester
i'm saying yeah
he's like have you got friends outside
saying yeah so have they got guns i'm
saying yeah
he's like so
if you can get me
over the wall
that's
um i think it was
a mill so it was him and someone else so
we said i'll give you a mill and he'll
give you a mill
so at this point i'm sat there
scratching my head thinking how can i
get this man over the wall
a few days later because what he started
doing he started pressing the general
alarm so when you press the general arm
in prison
all the officers from everywhere come
running to that point now they kept
doing that to time how long it takes the
officers to come so there was a
full-fledged planning action and i was a
part of it and i didn't even realize
that i did realize it was just due to
immaturity and stupidity i've agreed to
it you know i mean
but then somehow the officers have
got wind of it so and he got sent to the
segregation
and that's what saved me because i would
have got myself in a lot of trouble
what do you think you missed most about
outside life
that's a mad one you know because
after a few years in
it's like you shot off from the outside
world
so everything just becomes
like say
a memory
you know like
you kind of forget about things so
with things like
let's say
you have a partner outside you forget
what
the touch actually feels like if you
know what i mean so everyone will say oh
i can't wait to get out for this all for
that but in reality you forget what that
is you're just so used to being in that
environment you forget what is you
forget what it's like to
um
even sleeping in the bed with someone
else
even having someone else in a room with
you living with someone else you're
trapped in an environment where you're
just on your own
you know and
prison's full of
ego and pride so
we can't talk about real life emotions
you know what i mean so
for me
it was just being trapped in that
environment i forgot about the outside
world
what was the worst things you've seen
and experienced in prison
um
against being in the high security
sector
people people like
i seen some guy get his throat slit over
a rumor that turned out to not even be
true
yeah either after
toughen up or
become a victim
to be honest but then after us after a
few years in i would say after like five
years of your sentence
it just becomes the norm
you know it just becomes a normal thing
so rather than
chasing
say release and focusing on the outside
world
you just live day by day
did you make a decision to turn your
life around
going into prison i already knew
the charges they had me on and i knew i
was getting a long time
my gran was already old at that point so
i'm thinking with all these years she's
probably not going to make it i was on
the phone to my mum
and my mom saying like
we've been to the doctors today and the
doctor's saying there's not much long
left so i've said put my gram on the
phone
so i'm speaking to my grand speaker to
my gran
and
my head's telling me my heart's telling
me
tell her you love her tell her you love
her
but then my head's like won't allow me
to say it do you know what i mean so i
put all that to put that down to
this fake image i had of myself this
fake persona i used to put on
you know so then
but i couldn't go off the phone it's
like i kept saying to myself say it say
it say
but then it just wouldn't come out then
the next day i phoned home again but
this time i said you know what i'm going
to say i'm going to say it and this time
when i phone my mom said
she's gone then that's when reality hit
me then
like
everything else
all the peer pressure what other people
are going to say all these type of
things that all went out the window you
know because
now this has happened and this is the
day i've been dreading since i got to
prison
and i thought to myself you know what
like i'm not doing this normal
so i mean i'm not doing it
at first
the way i was thinking so it's like i
was thinking to myself
all right so
i'm not a gang member anymore i'm not
gonna get involved in any gang activity
when i get out i'm not gonna
like walk the streets with a firearm
but then i'm also thinking
but i need money in these things so i
might get out and get involved with
some drug dealers what i meant in prison
i might get involved with some armed
robbers what i met in prison so i still
had a criminal mindset
yeah you might not be an active gang
member but you're still selling drugs
you might not be an active gang member
but you're still deciding to be involved
in armed robberies
you know and that's when i thought
even that's not good enough because even
that could um send me back to prison so
that's when i decided to start getting
my education started my vocational um
courses all these type of things
when you got out of prison how old were
you
um i was thirty oh my god
i remember the first day i got out
i was in an apartment with my partner
then when i was waiting for the taxi to
take me back to the bail hostel we was
just stood outside so me and her were
just speaking
then the cars pulled up to a giveaway
with like four
males in with the windows down so in my
head
that's a drive-by
you know because that's what we was used
to
so then it's like i've blacked out so
i'm saying to her go back inside go back
inside she's not realizing what i'm
saying she can just hear me shout and go
back inside so she's like no i'm not
going back inside when we're going back
inside for
so then i'm saying so please go inside
go inside started like panicking so then
she started walking racing and i've
charged at the car
but then as i started charging the car
they've all looked at me like
what's he doing and just drove off
normal you know and that's when i've
realized like
i'm still trapped you know because
before that point i would say like i'm
done i'm out of it
i'm a citizen law-abiding citizen now
but
in reality with things like that
it's like it showed me that
you're still mentally trapped
you know did you feel judged by a
society about because of your criminal
yeah 100
100 it's like as soon as i got out like
because of i was on goal mode so i
thought i need to keep active so i think
i got out on
the monday
by the first day
i was sat
am having an interview
as soon as i mention my criminal record
they're like no no
no it's not happening no no
and then that was that was say i would
say one of the worst points for me
because that's when i'm having that tug
of war in my head so i'm thinking
i'm trying to change but you don't want
to give me a chance so what's the point
you know
can't be angry at the employer
you know because like i said it was my
decisions but then i'm thinking to
myself
why are you trying to change when nobody
wants to give you a chance
and i know for a fact i could just make
one phone call and be right back in the
position i left
in 2007.
can you talk us through we do now what
i'm doing now is um
mentor and facilitator for a charity st
jobs trust here in london
so what they do is they hire mentors and
facilitators with lived experience so
then
we use that lived experience to reach
the younger generation and speak to them
as much as the police have got a job to
do
and they've admitted it themselves that
they always look at the young person as
a perpetrator when a lot of the time
that young person is a victim
you know so for me growing up
i never woke up and decided you know
what i want to be a gang member today
what is the main advice
you can you give them those those young
people who go through the same
thing the main advice i give them is
it's
it's it's fake it's false you know it's
short-lived
you know so it's like
first time i got arrested i was probably
about 14.
four years later i'm sat in prison
and then
you go to prison drop out of um school
college whatever it is you're gonna have
to do it again anyway
you know you have to do these things you
have to have an education you have to
have some type of qualifications to even
survive as an adult outside
people ask me all the time like um
how do you feel how do people from your
past feel what happens if um
a rival gang member sees you or this or
that and i'm saying to them like
the mission i'm on the journey i'm on
outweighs everything anything anyone can
say
you know like my passion is
to raise awareness to this younger
generation like you don't have to go
through what i went through
[Music]
the cars pulled up in front all the
windows started coming through bam bam
all the guns are out i'm seeing old bill
standing everywhere next thing
the windows have all busted in
all the windows have come through i mean
i've been pulled out the back window in
the car